In the video about the potassium-sodium pump
we talked about how it helps the cell to figure out
its membrane potential of rest.
This is done through the active pumping of
three sodium ions outside the cell, and two potassium ions inside the cell.
We have a ratio of three to two,
but it alone can not create
membrane potential of rest.
Besides the potassium-sodium pump, potassium ions can
to go out of the cell through diffusion towards their concentration gradient.
They pass from outside to inside.
Naturally, there is a balancing power
or balancing factor. This is the charge.
If the outside is more positive than the inside,
positively charged ions, such as potassium ions,
they will not want to go up there.
The reason is their positive charge.
Here is more positive than here.
In fact, potassium ions will want to return to the cage. But because of its concentration gradient
will be pushed to the bottom of this channel more often,
than at the top.
There will be a balance.
They will begin to diffuse,
but there will be no equalization of concentrations on both sides of the membrane,
because the charge will hold them here (inside the cage).
And what happens to sodium ions?
Sodium ions are concentrated more and more
here above. Therefore, the charge above is here
increasingly positive.
If we did not have a membrane
and if we only looked at the concentration,
sodium ions would naturally be
to diffuse downwards.
We have a high concentration gradient here
and low here.
If there was no membrane, the sodium ions would naturally have
from a higher concentration point to a lower one.
This is their concentration gradient.
We said the membrane was
much more positive than that,
than from this one.
We can say there is a positive potential difference
between this and that country.
Therefore, positively charged ions, such as sodium ions here,
will want to go down because of their charge.
There are two reasons why they want to
to move from this side of the membrane to that
side of the membrane.
Their concentration gradient and their charge,
the electrical potential.
There is potential energy that comes from their desire
to escape from all these positive charges.
Combined Motivation of
sodium ions to move in that direction we call
electrochemical gradient.
Electrochemical
gradient.
I already said it once, but I will repeat it.
This is a combination of the electric gradient
and the chemical gradient.
We have a higher concentration in the chemical gradient
here than here. Particles want to diffuse down.
More particles will hit in this side of the membrane than
in this. If she did not have the membrane,
we would have a net stream of sodium ions down.
But if we think about the electric potential,
this country is more positive than that.
Therefore, positive ions will want to move down.
We can look at this gradient as a source of
potential energy.
And the cells really use it
sodium electrochemical gradient
as a source of energy.
Let's say this protein here
is a symptom.
This is a symbol.
He uses the electrochemical
gradient of one ion, in this case sodium,
uses that soda wants to
go through the membrane. The simporter uses this energy.
Imagine how the water falls from a waterfall
can move a turbine or mill.
Similarly, the symptom uses the energy of sodium,
which moves in the direction of its electrochemical gradient.
Sodium wants to move in that direction for two reasons -
concentration and electrical potential.
Or we can say - electrostatic charge.
The simporter uses this energy to transport other things.
The most famous symptom is sodium
and glucose.
Sodium and glucose will be
transported together.
Glucose will be transported
contrary to its concentration gradient.
If we move something in the direction,
contrary to its concentration gradient,
we must use active transport.
Let's draw
the concentration gradient of glucose to make it clearer.
It looks like this.
We have a high concentration in the cage
low concentration outside of it.
The cell may not want to waste all this glucose,
she wants to have as much glucose as possible
in the interior.
That is why you will need active transport,
in order to transport glucose, contrary to its concentration gradient.
To move in that direction.
But here is the source of energy thanks,
at which glucose transport will take place, contrary to its concentration gradient.
The source is the potential energy coming in
of the electrochemical gradient of sodium.
Transport where
we use energy accumulated from another species
active transport - in our case the potassium-sodium pump,
is called secondary active transport.
What is going on in here?
This sodium and glucose syringe performs secondary active transport.
Secondary active transport.
Uses the accumulated energy
of the electrochemical gradient of one ion.
Uses this accumulated energy to carry out active transport
of another molecule - glucose, back to
its concentration gradient.